23 glasses off business time Wesley so
he's got to choose his first move which
porn it's the title match he does just
Jad the king and one B3 Magnus Carlson
shakes his head he is surprised Magnus
was not expecting this I can't tell if
he's more surprised or offended B3 is
not an opening you see at the highest
levels of Chess at least not in this
time patol you usually see it in Blitz
chess but Magnus probably didn't take it
so seriously considering Wesley he
seemed to use it just to get something
Magnus has not even played his very
first move wow not many people in World
Chess have the courage to play this type
of opening against Magnus Carlson
usually they're trying to occupy the
center trying to force the issue and
look at Magnus he's bemused he's uh just
shocked here looking up at the ceiling
just trying to pick uh